cet homme est le représentant du groupe
espagnol casa ibères cacao
seul candidat à la reprise de la
chocolaterie il n'a pas souhaité
s'exprimer devant la caméra mais ajuste
donner un chiffre
sa dernière proposition canton nombre de
salariés repris le repreneur parlait de
passer à 65 salariés repris c'est
exactement ce qu'on lui a demandé ce qui
a priori été acceptée on attend que
c'est pareil on attend que soit
formalisée aujourd'hui l'offre par 13 65
personnes effectivement l'audience
d'aujourd'hui a duré quatre heures il a
fallu lever ce qu'on nomme des
conditions suspensives
si la caisse d'epargne par exemple qui
possède certaines machines de la
chocolaterie avait refusé de les vendre
cela aurait suspendu le processus
rien de ce genre ne s'étant produit la
procédure est sur le point d'aboutir
selon toute vraisemblance ibères cacao
sera donc le repreneur que pensent les
syndicats de cette entreprise madrilène
fondée en 1939
cette fois on a vraiment affaire à un
industriel et non pas à 10 capitaux de
deux hollandais qui croyaient faire une
bonne affaire
on a des capitaux en plus familiaux avec
des gens qui sont prudents comme des
industriels doivent l'être lorsque
ils reprennent une entreprise qui a eu
autant de difficultés hibbert cacao se
seraient engagés à ne pas délocaliser
aurait augmenté son offre financière
pour les actifs de l'entreprise et
serait également disposé à acquérir le
site lui même
autant de points qui laissent deviner un
véritable projet industriel mais avec un
gros bémol ça donne des perspectives
pour l'entreprise donc mais
malheureusement ça ne donne pas pour les
plus de 100 130 salariés qui seront
certainement l'essentiel mercredi 31
janvier une toute dernière audience se
tiendra au tribunal de commerce qui
rendra son délibéré le 5 février